[Music]
scientists have pieced together a pretty
clear picture of what life was like on
Earth thousands even millions of years
ago
but if you fast forward one million
years from now would alien civilization
be doing the same to learn about us
what would Earth look like one million
years from now
what remains of human civilization would
still be around
and would we end up clones in a human
version of Jurassic Park
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens came to Earth a million
years in the future
we're living in the anthropocene Epic
and in this historical period the human
impact on the world around us has been
significant enough to geologically alter
it
100 years from now it could be an era
defined by ecological collapse and mass
extinction
big bummer right
now there's no way for us to know how or
when our species may take its final walk
on our home planet a team of alien
scientists could find evidence of
nuclear fallout climate change or maybe
a massive asteroid that ended our
existence
or maybe they'd even find us already
living on another planet
but even if you settle on another planet
it's still no reason to live without
grammarly grammarly premium is the
convenient powerful tool you need to
take your writing to the next level
whether on a couch on Earth or typing in
a spaceshift and we're not just talking
a few words here and there grammarly's
smart ai-powered writing assistant
offers whole sentence rewrites so you
can communicate clearly and concisely
and the built-in tone detector makes
sure that every word comes across in
your voice so focus on the big picture
and let grammarly sweat the details
right now what if viewers can get 20 off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com what
if that's 20 off at
grammarly.com what if trust me you don't
want to wait a million years to take
advantage of this deal
one million years from now you'd be an
alien on board a Starship that has just
entered into orbit around Earth I can't
tell if you're joking or not but despite
your best efforts to scan the planet
below for intelligent life you'd find
nothing
your trip down to the surface would be
slightly delayed by an ongoing super
volcanic eruption
the planet would be blanketed in the
darkness of Ash
you might even have to wait a few years
for your alien crew to clean it up
before you could even land
finally you'd get approval to visit
Earth
down there you'd find everything to be
Barren and lifeless
storms fires and earthquakes would have
erased nearly all signs of immediately
visible life
but your team of archaeologists and
paleontologists would know that if they
wanted to find evidence of past
civilizations they better start digging
you'd be investigating what are called
boundary layers these are geological
signatures that indicate a transition
from one period to the next
so you'd be looking for animal and plant
fossils as well as changes in rock
layers
you could find a thin layer of clay that
marks the boundary to our anthropocenic
era the top layer would contain not much
more than small fossilized remains of a
few plant species
the layer below would contain older rock
but not only that there would be an
abundance of diverse plant fossils this
would be a breakthrough for your team as
they've now confirmed there was some
form of mass extinction period
as you searched through this layer the
nature of what happened to Earth over
the past million years would be revealed
you'd discover an unnatural amount of
carbon deposits from fossil fuel
emissions
evidence of global temperature changes
and widespread chemical pollutants
but the effects of climate change may
have reversed themselves over the one
million years humans have been absent if
your team were to uncover the regions
where our Coastal populations used to be
you excavate the remains of cities
relatively well preserved in the
sedimentary rock
imagine discovering the ancient subway
tunnels and sewers of New York
but nothing you would find would be in
pristine condition
bricks would have gone from their
characteristic red TO gray and steel
would have rusted and dissolved leaving
only imprints in the soil
finally you'd make the biggest discovery
of all
fossilized human bones
just like the dinosaurs these two would
most likely only be found encased in
sedimentary rock
almost all of the fossils of dinosaurs
that we discovered today are from
species that would have lived near lakes
or rivers that flooded
floods covered their remains in mud and
silt very quickly and this prevented
their bones from rotting the same would
apply to homo sapiens
your alien team would piece together the
puzzle that many of these human fossils
were the result of catastrophic floods
or tsunamis
and based on how much these bones have
fused with the Rocks around them your
team could start to assemble a timeline
of our unfortunate demise
usually bones take decades to decompose
if buried in a dry environment like a
funeral casket that could last for 100
years
mummified bones can survive thousands of
years
finding any of these would tell your
team that the last humans to walk the
earth weren't all that far in the past
but discovering only fossilized remains
would reveal our Extinction point being
further back than you'd hoped
there wouldn't be any samples of soft
tissues like muscles just rocks that
used to be bones
oh but you'd probably find fossilized
plastic in the layers of sedimentary
rock too it's not yet known how long
plastic waste needs to decompose into
organic matter
it could take hundreds of years maybe
thousands
or as you and your crew could discover
Millions
what you'd keep your hopes up for would
be the real Holy Grail
human DNA
the oldest DNA samples found in our
modern times date back 800 000 years and
come from insects and plants
but studies conclude that DNA could take
about 7 million years to disintegrate
and Eureka you'd find human DNA samples
trapped in ice cores in what was once
Greenland
now the big question would be what do
you do with them
study human genetics for scientific
purposes or have a little fun
one idea would be to clone these ancient
humans you could even create some kind
of Jurassic Park filled with people they
accept it would be called anthropocene
Park
and based on all that you'd put together
about our tragic history there would be
so many entertaining things to do in
this amusement park
maybe you could clone other animals and
play a game of mass extinction the
winner would be the one who could kill
the most species in the shortest amount
of time
you could dig for hidden oil reserves
increase carbon emissions for fun to
watch ice birds melt or how about a game
of nuclear war
sadly though you and the other
scientists probably wouldn't be able to
figure out what life was like for humans
at the end of our civilization
unless you'd find some of our still
living descendants that were born on the
red planet next door
but that's a story
for another
what if